salió para ver los efectos en la orilla
de una reciente tormenta.
En una zona de hierba justo hasta donde llega el agua,
encontró un traje de buzo.
Era gris y negro y parecía barato.
Por el final de cada pierna del traje
salían un par de huesos blancos.
Sin duda eran los restos de un humano.
En Noruega, los cadáveres suelen identificarse rápido.
y la policía empezó a investigar
en informes de desapariciones de la zona,
en informes nacionales.
buscaron en accidentes que pudieran tener relación.
No encontraron nada.
Realizaron una prueba de ADN
y, a través de la Interpol, buscaron en el extranjero.
Nada.
Era persona que parecía que nadie echara de menos.
Una vida invisible hacia una tumba sin nombre.
Entonces, un mes después,
la policía noruega recibió un mensaje de la policía holandesa.
Un par de meses antes, habían encontrado un cadáver
en un traje de neopreno idéntico y no sabían quién era la persona.
La policía holandesa pudo restrear el traje
a través de un chip de radiofrecuencia cosido al traje.
Así pudieron afirmar
que ambos trajes los compró la misma persona, a la misma hora.
El 7 de octubre de 2014,
en la ciudad francesa de Calais en el canal de la Mancha.
Y eso fue todo lo que pudieron saber.
Ese cliente pagó en efectivo.
No había cámaras de seguridad en la tienda.
Fue caso cerrado.
Oímos la historia,
y Tomm Christiansen, fotógrafo, quedamos impactados.
Nos hicimos la inevitable pregunta: ¿quiénes eran esas personas?
Aunque a penas sabía nada de Calais,
me llevó dos o tres segundos averiguar que
Calais era conocida por dos cosas.
Es la zona de Europa continental más cercana a Gran Bretaña.
Muchos inmigrantes y refugiados viven en un campamento
e intentan cruzar hasta Gran Bretaña a toda costa.
Ahí había una posible teoría sobre la identidad de los cadáveres
y la policía intuyó lo mismo también.
Si Uds. yo u otra persona conectados a Europa
desapareciera en la costa de Francia, la gente lo sabría.
Amigos o familia denunciarían su desaparición,
la policía le buscaría, la prensa lo anunciaría
y pondrían fotos en farolas.
Es difícil desaparecer sin dejar rastro.
Aunque si huyes de la guerra de Siria
y tu familia, si es que aún tienes,
no sabe con certeza dónde estás
y estás aquí de forma ilegal
entre miles de personas que van y vienen a diario.
Claro que si desapareces un día nadie se dará cuenta.
La policía no te buscará porque nadie nota que has desaparecido.
Eso es lo que le ocurrió a Shadi Omar Kataf
y a Mouaz Al Balkhi, ambos sirios.
Tomm y yo fuimos a Calais por primera vez en abril
y después de tres meses investigando podíamos contar la historia
de dos jóvenes sirios que escaparon de la guerra de Siria
y, al no poder irse de Calais,
compraron trajes de buzo y se sumergieron en el intento
de cruzar a nado el canal de la Mancha hasta Inglaterra.
Es la historia de cómo todos tenemos un nombre
todo el mundo tiene una historia y todo el mundo es alguien.
Pero también es la historia de qué significa ser un refugiado en Europa.
Aquí es donde empezó nuestra búsqueda.
Esto es Calais.
Actualmente viven aquí entre 3000 y 5000 personas
en unas condiciones horribles.
Lo llaman el peor campamento de refugiados de Europa.
Acceso limitado a comida, acceso limitado a agua,
acceso limitado a sanidad.
Enfermedades e infecciones por todos lados.
Están atrapados ahí porque quieren llegar hasta Inglaterra
y poder solicitar asilo.
Y lo intentan escondiéndose en camiones que viajan en ferry,
o por el Eurotúnel.
O se cuelan por la noche en la terminal del túnel
para esconderse en los trenes.
La mayoría quiere ir a Inglaterra porque conocen el idioma
y creen que les resultará más fácil retomar sus vidas ahí.
Quieren trabajar, quieren estudiar,
quieren poder seguir viviendo sus vidas.
Muchos tienen estudios superiores y están cualificados.
Si vas a Calais y hablas con ellos, conocerás a abogados, políticos,
ingenieros, diseñadores gráficos, granjeros, soldados...
Encuentras todos los oficios.
Pero quiénes son estas personas
deja de saberse cuando hablamos de refugiados y de emigrantes
porque solemos usar estadísticas.
Si hay 60 millones de refugiados en total,
sobre medio millón han cruzado
este año el Mediterráneo para llegar hasta Europa
y unos 4000 viven en Calais.
Pero eso son solo cifras,
y las cifras no dicen nada sobre quiénes son esas personas,
de dónde vienen o por qué están aquí.
Quiero hablarles de uno de ellos.
Este es Mouaz Al Balkhi, 22 años, de Siria.
Supimos de él la primera vez que estuvimos en Calais,
buscando respuestas a la hipótesis para los dos cadáveres.
Tras un tiempo, oímos la historia
de un hombre sirio que vivía en Bradford, Inglaterra,
y que había buscado desesperado a su sobrino Mouaz durante meses.
Resultó que la última vez que alguien supo algo de Mouaz
fue el 7 de octure de 2014.
El mismo día en que se compraron los trajes.
Viajamos hasta allí y conocimos al tío.
Le tomamos muestras de ADN
y también se tomaron muestras del pariente de Mouaz más cercano,
que vive en Jordania.
Los análisis concluyeron
que el cuerpo encontrado en la playa, en Holanda,
era de Mouaz al Balkhi.
Mientras realizábamos toda esta investigación,
pudimos conocer la historia de Mouaz.
Nació en la capital siria de Damasco en 1991.
Se crió en una familia de clase media.
Su padre, el del centro, es ingeniero químico
que pasó 11 en la cárcel por pertenecer a la oposición política.
Durante la ausencia de su padre,
Mouaz asumió la responsabilidad de cuidar de sus 3 hermanas.
Él era así, nos dijeron.
Mouaz estudió ingeniería eléctrica
en la Universidad de Damasco.
Tras dos años del comienzo de la guerra,
la familia dejó Damasco y viajaron hasta el país vecino.
En Jordania, su padre no podía encontrar trabajo
y Mouaz no pudo seguir con sus estudios.
Pensó: "Lo mejor que puedo hacer para ayudar a mi familia
es ir a algún lugar donde pueda acabar mis estudios
y encontrar un trabajo".
Así que, viajó a Turquía.
En Turquía, no le aceptaron en ninguna universidad
y al haberse ido Jordania como refugiado no podía volver a entrar al país.
Entonces, decidió irse al Reino Unido,
donde vivía su tío.
Consigue llegar a Argelia, camina hasta Libia,
paga a un traficante de personas para poder llegar en barco a Italia
y, desde allí, se dirige a Dunkerque,
una ciudad que está al lado de Calais, en el canal de la Mancha.
Sabemos que intentó cruzar sin éxito el canal hasta 12 veces
escondiéndose en un camión.
En algún momento, tuvo que perder toda fe.
La última noche que estuvo vivo,
se hospedó en un hotel barato cerca de la estación de tren de Dunkirk.
Vimos su nombre en el registro. Parece que se hospedó allí solo.
Al día siguiente, se fue a Calais, entró en una tienda de deportes
un par de minutos antes de las 8 de la tarde,
junto con Shadi Kataf.
Ambos compraron trajes de buzo
y la mujer de la tienda
fue la última persona que sabemos los vio con vida.
Intentamos averiguar dónde se conocieron Shadi y Mouaz,
pero no pudimos lograrlo.
Los dos tienen una historia similar.
Nos enteramos de quién era Shadi cuando su primo, que vive en Alemania,
leyó la traducción al árabe de la historia de Mouaz en Facebook.
Contactamos con él.
Shadi, un par de años mayor que Mouaz,
también se crió en Damasco.
Era un hombre trabajador.
Montó una tienda de neumáticos y trabajó en una empresa de edición.
Vivía con su numerosa familia,
pero bombardearon su casa cuando empezó la guerra.
Huyeron hasta Damasco, a una zona llamada Campo Yarmouk.
Yarmouk es descrito como el peor sitio para vivir
de todo el planeta.
Les ha bombardeado el ejército, les han asediado,
les ha atacado el ISIS
y, durante años, se les ha interrumpido el suministro.
Un oficial de la ONU fue el año pasado
y dijo: "Se han comido todo el césped y ya no queda nada".
De una población de 150 000,
al parecer, solo 18 000 personas siguen viviendo en Yarmouk.
Shadi y sus hermanas escaparon.
Sus padres aún siguen atrapados allí.
Shadi y una hermana suya huyeron a Libia.
Fue después de la caída de Gaddafi,
pero antes de que en Libia estallara una guerra civil.
Justo en ese último período de estabilidad en Libia,
Shadi empezó a bucear y pasó sus días bajo el agua.
Se enamoró del océano.
Cuando decidió que no podía quedarse más tiempo en Libia,
a finales de agosto de 2014,
esperaba encontrar trabajo de buceador una vez en Italia.
La realidad no fue tan fácil.
No averiguamos mucho de sus viajes
porque nos costó ponernos en contacto con su familia.
Lo que sí sabemos es que luchó.
A finales de septiembre,
vivía en las calles de algún lugar de Francia.
El 7 de octubre llamó a su primo de Bélgica
y le contó su situación.
Le dijo: "Estoy en Calais. Necesito que vengas a por mi mochila y mi computadora.
No puedo pagar a los contrabandistas para poder cruzar hasta Gran Bretaña,
pero voy a cruzar a nado con una traje de buzo".
Su primo, claro está, intentó disuadirle,
el móvil de Shadi se quedó sin batería
y nunca más se volvió a encender.
Lo que quedó de Shadi lo encontraron 3 meses después,
a 800 kilómetros,
en una playa de Noruega con un traje de buzo.
Aún está esperando su funeral en Noruega
y nadie de su familia podrá asistir.
Muchos pensarán que la historia de Shadi y Mouaz
es una historia sobre la muerte.
Yo no estoy de acuerdo.
Para mí, es una historia sobre dos preguntas que todos nos hacemos:
¿Qué es una vida mejor?
¿Qué estoy dispuesto a hace para tenerla?
Para mí, y para la mayoría de Uds.,
una vida mejor sería
poder tener más tiempo para lo que creemos es significativo,
ya sea pasar más tiempo con la familia y los amigos,
viajar a un lugar exótico,
tener dinero para comprar lo último en tecnología
o las zapatillas de moda.
Todo esto lo podemos tener fácilmente,
pero si huyes de una zona de guerra,
las respuestas a esas preguntas son dramáticamente distintas.
Una vida mejor es una vida a salvo.
Es una vida digna.
Una vida mejor significa que no bombardeen tu casa,
no temer que puedan capturarte.
Significa poder enviar a tus hijos a la escuela,
ir a la universidad
o encontrar un trabajo para mantenerte a ti y a los tuyos.
Una vida mejor sería un futuro con ciertas posibilidades
en comparación con ninguna.
Y eso es una motivación muy grande.
Me es fácil imaginar
que, después de pasar semanas y meses,
como un ciudadano de segunda clase,
viviendo en la calle o en un campamento improvisado
con un nombre racista y malsonante como "La jungla",
la mayoría de nosotros haría lo que fuera.
Si pudiera preguntarles a Shadi o Mouaz,
justo en el momento en que se hundieron en las aguas heladas del canal,
seguramente me dirían: "Vale la pena arriesgarse".
Ya no veían que les quedara otra opción.
Eso es desesperación.
Y esa es la realidad de ser un refugiado en la Europa Occidental de 2015.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Gracias, Anders.
Este es Tomm Christiansen,
el fotógrafo que tomó las fotos que habéis visto trabajando juntos.
Tomm, los dos habéis estado en Calais hace poco.
Fue el tercer viaje.
Después de la publicación del artículo.
¿Qué ha cambiado? ¿Qué habéis visto allí?
Tomm Christiansen: La primera vez que fuimos a Calais,
habían unos 1.500 refugiados.
Lo estaban pasando mal, pero eran optimistas, tenían esperanza.
La última vez, el campamento había crecido hasta unas 4.000 o 5.000 personas.
Parecía estar más asentado, habían llegado ONGs,
se había abierto una escuela.
Lo cierto es que los refugiados se han quedado más tiempo,
y el gobierno francés ha logrado acordonar las fronteras mejor,
por eso La jungla esta creciendo,
y también la desesperación y la desesperanza de los refugiados.
BG: ¿Pensáis volver y continuar denunciando la situación?
TC: Sí.
BG: Anders, yo antes era periodista,
y me parece increíble que en este clima de
salarios recortados y editores en crisis,
Dagbladet ha proporcionado muchos recursos para esta historia,
lo que sugiere que los periódicos están tomando las riendas,
¿cómo la vendísteis a vuestros editores?
Anders Fjellberg: Al principio fue difícil
porque no podíamos saber lo que íbamos a averiguar.
Cuando nos enteramos
de que podíamos identificar quién era el primer cadáver,
recibimos el mensaje de que podíamos hacer lo que quisiéramos,
viajar adónde necesitáramos y hacer lo que tuviéramos que hacer.
Acabar el trabajo.
BG: Eso es un editor asumiendo la responsabilidad.
Esta historia se ha traducido y publicado
en varios países europeos y seguro se seguirá haciendo.
Y todos queremos leer vuestras novedades. Gracias, Anders. Gracias, Tomm.
(Aplausos)